what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
live streaming it's probably not even
going to be a series I'm not going to
lie to you guys that would be
gaslighting and I don't do that but what
I will tell you is I'm going to react to
different videos um make sure you like
the video guys don't be
annoying
honestly you know a like is free all you
have to do is like the video okay so
today I wanted to start this this show
by talking about my Twitter so you guys
know I love to I oh my gosh I have 9,99
posts on Twitter wow I tweet a lot this
is in like the span of six
months
um okay let me let me pull this
up wait how do I
I got it see I'm doing good I'm doing
good thank you can you guys hear me okay
please let me know in the chat can you
hear can
you can you hear me is everything
good
um
okay um you guys said good morning I
love you Pro I love you too I love you
too we're lovers not Fighters out here
okay uh I'm reading the chat right now I
need you guys to let me know that the
audio is working because as as a woman
obviously I don't do the audio right hit
the like thank you thank you for the
support yes yes yes yes so today I'm
just a tweeter I'm an expert
Tweeter now guys mind you I've grown
this Twitter
following in like six months literally
six months
yes I wasn't that big on Twitter before
that
um now my first
tweet oh I had a lot of tweets my first
tweet that I put out today I just
decided I woke up and I chose violence
you know some days I wake up and I
choose peace other days I wake up and I
choose violence so what I did was I said
there are zero Pros to dating a single
mother now I want you to know how I came
to these conclusions now Pearl isn't
that harsh isn't that don't you know
women that have been married as single
mothers yes yes I do and there are
exceptions to every rule but exceptions
don't make the rule
so um there's a researcher that helps me
do research here on the channel he he's
been on a couple couple panel shows his
name is Dr David Baker and we ran the
numbers and he told me that roughly
roughly 15% of single mothers get a guy
to marry them I think it was 12% but
we're just going to Ball Park 22% of
single mothers get a guy to live with
them so what is that tell me what does
that tell me out of single mothers hey
half over half will not have a happy
ending that the
right and the left really does what I
call selling dreams selling dreams to
these women oh yes there's someone for
everyone no there's not if you're a
narcissistic [__] there is nobody for
you um but they call me the mean one for
saying this okay now so I said there are
zero um Pros to dating a single mother
we have Sergio here my baby mother just
got married well she was one of the
15% and here we talk about the rule we
don't talk about exceptions talking
about exceptions is a very feminine
Behavior a as people we have to know you
have to talk in general and we have to
come to conclusions
okay you don't really understand what
attack attack in women all day does
nothing now I I don't understand how
it's an attack to say that there's zero
Pros to dating a single
mother my real question is is it true or
is it untr and so many times guys you
guys focus on oh and you focus on the
way this makes women
feel and I say to hell with how this
makes women feel
truth is truth regardless of who says it
now I'll give you an example A Gentleman
on the show came on last night and said
he will not date women over the age of
24 well I'm I'm
26 and I could have gotten mad and
gotten angry and said there's so many
Pros to dating me I'm so amazing and
awesome or you could just take it in and
you could say
okay and live with the fact that truth
is truth regardless of who says it and
it is not an attack just because women
don't like that for example if I said
there is no Pros there are zero Pros to
dating a homeless man would the men come
in and say oh no but the homeless men
but but or there is zero Pros to dating
a man without a job would they come out
and say oh but Pearl's the big big
meanie the big meanie yeah
okay he his next
um his next claim is there will always
be a beta simp to take that role and my
question really is overwhelmingly
they're not taking that role they are
not getting remarried so like me or Love
Me Or Hate Me What I'm saying is
true my mom was a single mom and she's
been married over 20 years mean while
you're still single and have never had
anybody love you what
nobody not even my mom like come on all
right hopefully the incels following
catch on to your grift
soon guys do you know how much easier it
would have been to just Pander to wom
and watch me watch me Pander watch me
Pander okay I'm gonna I'm going to make
this this could this could just you know
now I could be the ultimate making a ton
of money person okay now imagine yes
right here I
say you are
special really and truly you are special
and you deserve the man that is going to
make you happy you are not for everybody
there is somebody out there for you God
has somebody out there for you boom I
can make millions
oh my and then put some skin care
products at the
end oh my gosh it's like they'll call me
a grifter what am I selling I do sell
women shouldn't vote t-shirts but like
do you know how much more money I could
make off of like I don't know some skin
care lines or whatever
like anyways why does there have to be
Pros why can't sorry I'm reading here
why does there have to be Pros why can't
you just love people
people um I Feel Like Loving the woman
is a pro in itself let me get this
straight let me get this
straight the
pro is loving the
woman that is the value ad that is the
the
cell that's the the the hard cell that
you're given to these guys you're saying
yes yes now they're saying not even my
mom but my mother yes even your mother
it was bad deal for your dad your dad
took a bad deal yeah a lot of you women
are going to have to find out that your
dad took a terrible deal terrible some
man it worked out for but for every one
man it worked out for there's five men
who it did not work out
for yes yes yes you're cruel and
disrespectful oh oh no no no
no I'm so cruel for saying don't date
single mothers there's zero
Pro but I think that gets you off does
it not is that that's like a weird
question um someday you're the you're
near the end of your Crusade you old
ugly alone and you're going to realize
your life was a waste and you were never
happy I'm a pretty I'm a pretty cheery
person you know what I mean but this
idea I don't even like the idea that we
chase after
happiness I think actually women chasing
after happiness has led to terrible
destruction
um so I'm I'm just so sick of these
simps guys my Lord this this stuff does
not help women okay so now I go I go on
I go on um and I
say oh I wanted to tell a story so there
was a recent show okay and on the show
so this guy this guy says he says I do
not date single mothers I don't want to
date the single mothers and there is a
single mother on the
show and this single mother nice enough
Woman Pretty Woman nothing against her
personally but I I want to demonstrate
how delusional women are um even the
nice nice ones okay after the show I
guess he messages her asks her for her
details
whatever
she comes to me and says this is proof
this is proof that the men even if they
say they don't like single moms they
they like the single
mothers it's like the men just said
they're interested in sex they just said
they would not be interested in a
relationship from a single mother yet
when the very men that say this that say
this they still believe that it's
because they are the special amazing
one statistically you will not be I wish
I wish all of the single mothers well I
really do but most single mother if
single so I I'm gonna
even and I have I have more more
thoughts so I I keep going I say
seriously guys stop sing Single Mothers
bring nothing to the table and there's
no benefit to raising another man's kids
if single mothers were getting Ser were
serious about getting remarried they
would give custody to the father so
now we have Captain saaho coming in the
men that are just basically women coming
in yeah
um uh no wait I wanted to find this one
the last one I did
oh if oh okay because I added I added
in that if single where is this but
there was a tweet and I said if single
mothers were
serious oh here we go okay all right
seriously guys stop sing there's no
benefit and single mothers bring nothing
to the table there is no benefit to a
man raising another man's kids if single
mothers were serious about getting
remarried they would give custom to the
father now I don't know who this man is
um I guess
Greek he sells organic baby formula
which cool I guess he's got some kids
all
right don't know what his backstory is
but typically and I want to I want to
give you guys some what I've noticed
typically the men that have this innate
protection of women either had a a weak
father or b a single mother or wife to
single mother it's usually one of those
three don't know who this is but if
single mothers were serious about
getting remarried they would give
custody to the father if the last sence
doesn't prove this account is grifting
you are sing to Pearl so what I've
noticed is the biggest simps and
grifters accuse me of sing and grifting
don't know who he is because they don't
have a good argument instead of asking
what did I say that was untrue what did
I say that was
what is what is not true about this
statement they say pearl is a grifter
blah blah blah and he's too stupid to
understand what why I say this to to
single mothers if a single mother
says if a single mother says I want to
remarry my goal is to get
remarried and they were serious about
the kids growing up in the best way
possible and you have a single mother
that is is worth marrying let's just say
it would be a single mother that
believes in patriarchy a single mother
that believes in true Traditional Values
which means the man is the head of the
household and therefore he should be
making the decisions on the children so
if single mothers were serious about
getting remarried they would give
custody to the father you should not
take a woman seriously who did not give
primary custody to the father unless
that father is a crack addict or
something crazy which why are you
dealing with a woman who has a crack
addict ex ex-husband okay not a good not
a good deal he should have custody the
kids turn out far better and it shows
you that that woman is not vindictive
and not spiteful and it is much easier
for a man to come in when the mother
only has the kids on weekends or every
other weekend four days a month is a
much easier cell as a single mother and
the kids turn out better so my argument
is if single mothers want to
remarry I would say take marriage off
the table and accept a long-term
relationship because you're more likely
to get that than
marriage and second and second I would
say give custody to the father so your
kids don't turn out to be homeless
cracken
addicts let him let the father make the
decisions about the children and give
him primary custody because it is going
to be
easier for you to get remarried or in a
long-term relationship if you give the
father primary custody and the problem
is most of these men that come in and
Sam grifting sing whatever this [__]
they're too stupid to understand the
statistics and the outcomes for kids
that are raised in a single mother
home men should be giving
custody um now I can't make you un
ignorant but I can try I can do my
best um so my second question I had on
Twitter today so that that's my point in
case as no don't ever date a single
mother there are very few exceptions I
would argue there's basically no
unicorns but the few unicorns that there
are would be okay giving custody to the
father because that shows that she can
submit to a guy's Authority yes yes yes
yes and it shows that she is not
vindictive and not spiteful my second
argument is don't ever date a woman that
says she was abused men have way too
much to
lose they have way too much to lose in
this
culture it
is it
is it is too risky for men to date a
woman that said she's been abused
because you are next you typically
attract what you are it is very uncommon
that a woman is just a perfect angel and
was not abusive at all
um and he
just he just got really mad and just
started abusing
her no no no not not not the norm not
the norm so I what I say is men have too
much to lose and do not date women that
say they were abused bad
idea they all say that Pearl what I mean
there's girls that don't say that okay
so so now that we started with my
Twitter my Twitter beefs of the
day we're going to go on
to um we're gonna go on to reacting to
Candace Owens on Bill
Maher yes I'm gonna give my commentary
which I'm GNA be honest guys I'm
not as political as
say you know my my expertise is more
around family law and the court system
but it'll be interesting to see Candace
Owens on Bill Maher let's let's pull it
up I actually think that Trump out of
office for a good reason well was a good
thing for your show because it allowed
you to it's not about my show Candace
that's insulting no no no
no I don't believe I don't believe in
chips I think we've established tonight
we've all got our own we all got our own
[Music]
things hello who is hiding in my
high this is awesome this is actually a
really sick man cave how are you my
husband has one but it's a lot small
it's not a man cave because I'm not a
husband it's a man cave it's not it's a
nightclub yeah but men need caves even
if they are don't have wives no no I
think they do this is a nightclub you
don't hear it oh I see you're with TR
you see how that's gynocentric a man
cave why does a man need a cave in his
own
house anyways wild I've been with child
for 3 years years I've been pregnant for
3 years I've had a baby in 2021 this is
like my permanent State now I'm
basically an elephant you do know that
science knows what causes this now I do
they know I actually been trying to
figure it out for the last three years
cuz it feels like it's a medical
condition so you're like having Irish
twins literally I have a 2-year-old a
one-year-old and this one's due in
November I've been pregnant for three
years so I think it's going to be weird
when I'm not pregnant anymore I'm going
to be like I don't know what to do with
myself what's what and what's that like
when you're always pregnant honestly
it's got to be rough it's not I I feel
like everyone has this like cultural
understanding of pregnancy and I think a
lot of women play it
up cultural no I feel like there's this
this alien knowing on you from the
inside yeah but it's like it's not that
big of a deal I got to be honest with
you it's it's like I for some women
obviously you can look at them and you
can tell which ones are having what
looks like an allergic reaction right um
and they have a rough to go with it but
some people just do pregnancy pretty
easily and I'm one of those people that
just kind of like it doesn't really
change anything so you're just going to
keep going no I wanted to do it all back
to back because I didn't want to be I
don't know when parents do the like we
had a kid and we waited five years for
the next one I'm like who wants to like
restart and take out all the bottles and
I just was like if I'm getting pregnant
I'm just going to have all of my kids
back to back right and then
one yeah I think it's genius so you do
believe in birth control you're not
doing it I actually don't believe in
birth control no you're just doing it
the Catholic way just like whatever Happ
my husband's so Catholic like Beyond
he's the Catholic Catholics 12 kids I
know it's dangerous of course it is it's
completely dangerous and stupid I'm on
your
side well what are you going to do trick
them and take birth control yeah just I
don't know Catholics they have a lot of
kids this is just yes I didn't choose
life thing when I was a kid
really where did you grow up New Jersey
okay yeah you definitely saw some 14
kids c yeah for sure for
sure but they were happy but you don't
want
you don't want that to be you I do kind
of I kind of want a school bus yeah yeah
like my colleague Matt wall she's got
six kids I feel I'm naturally
competitive oh my God yeah I know it's
really bad well it's bad I'm very very
competitive so I feel like now I might
just have six kids just seven just to
beat them it's really bad definitely bad
for the planet let's not get into that
right away bad to the planet oh my God I
mean kids are bad for the planet well
what everything they're pretty
eco-friendly actually
adults are bad for the planet well
they're not equ friendly in the sense
that they're going to have kids and you
know that you're just making more people
who are
using resources you know people who
argue about planet and you know Elon
Musk I don't understand his whole thing
about like we should have more people
it's like there's room of course there's
room it's not about room it's about
resources we don't have the resources we
have the room we just don't have I read
yest the other day where the uh what do
they call the groundwater we've already
like sucked out all the groundwater that
we can possibly use they're not there's
just not enough rain falling for like
all your kids it's all about you Candace
think you
it's so this guy knows the perfect
amount this man's an expert on on
rainfall
in his let me let me get this straight I
just want to understand the
argument if we have too many
children there won't be enough
rainfall all right it's interesting
because I've just kind of read this
whole book debunking all of that which I
feel like in two years you're going to
have a totally different perspective on
all that because I've seen your growth
and where you were a few years ago to
where you are now and you know Elon Musk
I think is probably pretty educated
about the
planet resources uh do you think no no
not necessarily not if not either are
you if you think that we can somehow
keep putting people on the planet which
has a finite amount of resources oh look
there's my zucchini that I gave to I was
looking for that look at that thing did
you grow that I I did and I gave it to
uh Viv when he was here a couple of
weeks ago he didn't take it unless
unless he took it and they put another
one just like it in there but I don't
think that let me see that can hand me
that thing I don't want to you actually
grow this this's actually a really big
zucchini I I told him I said you were
probably at the Iowa State Fair or and
they this is probably the kind of thing
that you I grow vegetables and I I just
want to tell you maybe he doesn't grow
them
that that's a very respectable zucchini
would you like it I actually would I
actually love zucchini so to remind you
not to get
pregnant now we going to leave it there
it's going to wind up staying there
again no it won't I won't leave it I
actually love zucchini great yeah it's
fantastic yeah this is my favorite I
actually did cucumbers this year and I
got some pretty big cucumbers but
they're wretched to
grow they just kind of grow out it's
almost a shame to have to cut into that
but you do yeah you you kind of but um
don't you not believe like in the moon
landing so I'm supposed to believe you
about climate I I think it's so funny
how people take well first off I know
okay okay all right let me
just all right all right hold on guys
I'm sorry can we just let's just watch
the moon landing video for a second here
I'm not I'm not saying I don't believe
in it okay I'm not I'm not saying
that
but I
mean 2 1 Zer alline r
like does this look real to you ft Down
2 and a half picking up some
dust ft 2 and a
half what what am I looking
at believe it I believe it
Charlie I mean I'm not I'm not saying I
believe it or I don't believe it I'm
just saying I could see why she's
skeptical what I'm talking about with
the climate stuff so I'm just going to
go ahead and promote well you're not the
only one yeah well I mean I think you
should probably realize like that there
is in the same way that there are
narratives I think you're now more awake
to The Climate hoax is one that runs
trillions of dollars and okay we are not
running out of space you could fit the
entire world if you stacked it like New
York City in Dallas so fit I just said
it's not about the point is is that the
F hurricanes are down the whole idea
that every time it rains it's because
you know something bad is happening is
like it's it's okay what I will agree
with you on is
this the environmentalists do often lie
because they have this idea uh this
issue is so important and by the way it
is so important that it's okay if we
shade the truth to get people on our
side and I don't agree with that I'm
always matter well not every time what
was your climate Des disaster growing up
mine was mine was global warming they
don't even say it anymore they don't say
global warming anymore they don't no
they say climate change they they went
from Global cool but in the world they
do no they don't they went from global
cooling to global warming they never
were in global no one was ever talking
about it was one that's such a stupid
talking point that you keep repeating
it's a zombie lie it was one article in
one magazine in one day one week in
Newsweek or something nobody was talking
about global cooling yes we understand
that the planet is always changing
that's a different story there was there
was a whole climate alarm alarmism via
the IPC for global cooling no there
was there was but do you believe people
landed on the moon well let's just back
that up you don't I think that I think
see now he's bringing up something that
doesn't have anything to do with the
conversation because she was
winning yes yes he is triggered that's a
standard for this discussion you are
taking something that was a Twitter you
can't answer joke I'm going to answer
your question but I'm just trying so I
think you should add context because
what you're doing now is you're jumping
away from an actual meaningful
discussion about climate change and the
hoax that's surrounding it and making
people fearful to have children and
you're lot going well didn't you once
tweet when I said literally I said in
the tweet it let's have some fun today
what is one conspiracy theory that
almost got you and that you think like
could possibly be be real and I said the
one that always gets me every time is
the moon landing how can we haven't gone
back so you're taking this one tweet
where people then shared the things that
they think that were not really serious
or political on this long thread to now
apply to a conversation about climate
change but just to be clear people did
land on the moon I don't know okay there
we go I don't know I do know I just want
to know why we didn't go back we did go
back what did we go back what year to
the Moon we people on the moon okay I'm
asking a serious question when when did
we go when did we go back to people
walking the moon 69 okay July 20th 1969
we went back like 10 more times who went
back who walked in the moon America you
know no but like what were the
astronauts names educate me why who the
[__] remembers what the astronauts names
were that's a big it's a pretty big deal
to walk on the moon the first guy and
then after that yes who else walked on
it I don't remember the name she's a
[__] that woman
she
she's destroying him right now
destroying him like another dozen okay
yeah are you we okay other dozen humans
walked on the Moon yes Americans all
Americans is the earth flat
guys is
the no no no that's stupid
no but I
mean no no no no that's
stupid but why would they fake at
no no we landed on the mood but why did
they get so mad about it like why did
why does everyone think that's so stupid
to oh no
no okay we don't remember we kept going
back uh Apollo 13 was the one they made
the movie about that was the one they
aborted but that was after we had landed
Apollo 11 I think was I'm not talking
about space missions I'm talking about
actual people walking yes landing on the
moon and walking on it first of all it's
it it is an impressive scientific feat
it's not out of the realm of like how
could that possibly happen it's only
250,000 miles away they had figured out
enough to be able to do it even with
these shitty computers that they had in
1969 um yes it's risky and we did lose
people doing it um but we did do it I
mean plainly I mean the idea that you
could think that this was some sort of
hoax I I'm sorry but it colors
everything else I I'm just saying that
like I'm just not like you're I feel
like you're just trying to find this one
I've never talked about this on my show
you're literally talking about one funny
tweet it's relevant it's really it's
that you won't say absolutely people
walked on the moon it's relevant I I
feel that he is so
condescending he's like um he looks like
one of the like liberal hippie dudes
from like the
70s you can kind of spot them out when
they're older like
um I don't know when you start to look
at people as like archetypes you kind of
see things differently so I W to I'm G
to show you guys something so like when
I see
um um wait hold on so like when I see
let's
say this girl that was reacting to me
the other day Al
well trying to think of
someone like
uh wait let me let me find it hold on
guys you are finding an angle here to
try to talk about something that I've
never talked about on my podcast I've
never talked people on on a debate
station College you you probably had a
producer dig up what you thought someone
said Pearl no chance we landed on the
moon Pearl you're incredible love what
you do and wish the world would listen
to you I'm listening thank you thank you
I'm just saying like I'm not sold on it
I'm not cuz the way they react the way
they react to the moon landing is the
same way they react when you question
anything about history like oh women had
to have been oppressed and then they
can't really tell you why they had to
have landed now I'm not even saying they
didn't
but why are we so close I'm an
open-minded gal where the most absurd
tweet
there's no way you it's out you're
saying it's out there there even
articles about this it's so obscure that
it's like it's like literally I I me
said like let's have some fun what are
some of the things that what are some
conspiracy theories that you read that
you have questions about and I was like
the moon landing first of all I promise
you there is no production on this show
it's a it's a pretty Niche thing of all
the things I talk about and I known for
there was even an article written about
this about me I wasn't planning to talk
about it it's like how here because you
saw it on Twitter I got here somehow I
knew it but how because it's out there
because read in my Wikipedia like it's
like it's so obscure it's so Niche that
I'm just like Curious I don't I don't
think that's the case because I think I
read it in the Vanity Fair article about
you no no nope I mean it's not it's not
even relevant for like it's I've never
ever had a single person sit down and
ask me this question just America a
service because we we we we find the
Baseline of your thinking I'm sorry but
that is relevant that you don't think
men landed on the mo I just said I would
like I first off I what I specifically
said was I want to know why and I think
even Elon Musk said this in his time
piece you guys don't believe in
dinosaurs are are dinosaurs not
real are who is hold on guys I need to
get them
to
okay ask him about it yeah him about he
did he did address it in his uh time I
think he probably believes it but I'm
just not interested in this topic I
heard okay I wanted to say this rumor
that I heard about billah now I'd like
to say this is a rumor this is a rumor I
swore that corn star came
up and said that she slopped with Bill
Maher I'm like pretty sure it was like
um she used to do podcast with
Britney Renner I'm like pretty
sure at all so it's just like you just
came in so fiery about something that I
am not known for but what I'm at like
why is he I mean like I could do the
same argument I mean aren't you he's
talking about how
her getting pregnant is bad for the
planet I mean isn't screwing a porn star
bad for everyone you sleep with after
and give super garia too do you know
what I mean like that was like an
obscure tweet of like it started with
let's have some fun and it was in a
joking Manner and suddenly you're like
how could you not believe the moon
landing and I'm like the
energy little my apology I I I don't
want this to be adversar it was just Sur
got on to Global Warming I
would okay to have this topic no but I I
connected it to that because it was like
okay but I'm in the public sphere
talking about that I've had experts on
my show talking about like Gregory
weinstone talked about his book about
the climate change hoax I care deeply
about that because of the implications
and how the climate change hoax and the
trillions of dollars that are basically
disappearing for things like Paris of
court agreement like I'm on very much on
record in and sincere not to beat a dead
horse but if you think the moon landing
is a hoax it colors my view of what you
think of the global warming being a h
yeah so now he's attacking the person
well if you have that opinion you must
be
wrong what about what she's saying is
untrue that's what we got to focus on
okay so let but I never said the moon
landing is a hoax you said I said name
one conspiracy
theory almost got you I said I don't
know anything about I don't know
anything about I can't even debate you
you're sitting here telling me that 12
men have gone on the moon since I don't
know anything about it and so I keep a
very I think that there's one thing that
people say about me is I don't come into
conversations about things that I don't
know so I'm not going to sit here
pretend to be an expert on moon landing
such a brilliant person things that I
actually know will I'm willing to
because I don't care I literally don't
it it's it's to me utterly
inconsequential for the work but I do
yeah I would that's why I said fun
thread tell me this like we were like
tell me what's one conspiracy theory
that you believe that we can look into I
mean we really should pull the Tweet
because it's it's weird that you're at
that you're making this so severe as if
I was like on a talk show debating the
moon landing and so what I'm saying is
I've never cared about this topic
because it's undebatable
completely
like making it debatable I don't think
anyone watching this will think that I
made this topic debatable I think you've
made this very debatable all I told you
was I sent a funny tweet and it's a
pretty obscure tweet that's never how's
life in ever discussed before how life
in Nashville Nashville's real right
Nashville is a real place and I love
Nashville it's really great yeah it's
it's interesting I was just in Austin
Texas and I feel like Austin and
Nashville are the two places were the
liberal diaspora shall we call it
liberals who want to get away and I
certainly understand why I live here in
California it is a ridiculous state that
drives you insane I totally get it I'm
too dug in here to make a change and
where else would I find Club random
but I get it I feel like those are the
two places they go they go to Austin and
they go to n yeah and it's annoying they
ruin they in a
state and then conservatives are like
all right we're going to go and fix this
state so we went to Vegas we went to
Florida and we went to Tennessee and now
the Liberals just have to come with
asille yeah because you're not really
out in the sticks I mean Austin's a
pretty liberal town and any city is blue
right okay so you're out of like the
fire but you didn't go to The Frying Pan
Am I is that about right um yeah yeah
that's pretty much it I mean for us we
were also between Texas and Tennessee
for sure we were probably between
Chattanooga and Dallas and we decided on
Nashville because I think a lot more
opportunities were happening like there
was a lot of La people coming starting
Studios daily wire mov to their Studio
from LA to Nashville so it felt like the
right place and I think at that time I
was having kids so you you sort of
naturally crave the suburbs when you
have kids obviously like the whole and
also York by the way if I was a parent
first of all it would be there' be
Unholy hell if I was a parent because
probably we're going to be on the same
page on this [__] some of the stuff that
goes on in the
schools is just so cray cray and I would
not be able to keep my mouth shut about
it so I'm sure a state like Tennessee
does not have I wonder if she
homeschools her kids laws that some of
the blue states do where like you you're
the the the parents are not allowed to
be
notified by the school they're PR
actually prohibited if the kid changes
their
gender like they say that would be
outing the student to a parent outing is
a word we even use in connection with a
parent shouldn't everything be out to
the parent yeah I'm sure I'm singing
from your Himel now am I allowed to have
an opinion on this or I'm just I'm just
trying to make up for my FAA with the
moon I just don't care I I'm just being
honest you I don't care about that at
all I literally nothing about it and I
wouldn't have ever picked a debate with
somebody about something that I just
don't care about but this I care deeply
about um and this is what I do a lot of
you know work in the space of talking to
parents and understanding how we've
become so removed from our our own
children systematically and you're right
that places like LA and New York have
become these major hubs where the state
has gone too far and I do a lot of work
on other stuff too that you would think
is weird and you know vaccine stuff for
parents and kind of giving them a guide
oh no I'm with you there okay I wasn't
sure about that um and you know I do I
produce entire separate series talking
about vaccines and sort of the increase
and I was a kid I I don't think vaccines
are a hoax or anything right I just not
a hoax but how you know do your kids
need from 1982 don't 6 to 75 you know I
mean my view just to be clear vaccines
are a tool in the medical kit just like
antibiotic can I just say that this Ted
Talk seems to lack practical Common
Sense Pearl you look wonderful without
makeup and I hope that this new found
internet Fame doesn't overshadow your
natural beauty thank you what a what I
am wearing makeup
but sorry I don't wear a lot I don't
wear a lot in that study where Amish
children don't have any disease like it
was like they have a basically 0% cancer
rate they're po I actually I don't even
think they're necessarily poisoning us I
think they're trying to make money in
the ways that they make money poon
poison us so they do but yeah mortality
rates when weight against third world
countries and you're being told that
this is because we're super healthy you
got kids 75 vaccines when I was a kid it
was it was 12 you know and there's been
an explosion people don't even know
anything about the diseases it's just
these constant fear campaigns and then
on top of that in States like La you
can't opt out you know so these are
things that parents have to think about
now where you're literally racing your
kids could you go to prison for saying
that I don't want my child referred to
as a different gender
behind my back yes depending on where
you live they trying to criminalize you
being a parent um and then you add that
to the you know medical complex and
maybe you say you know I am I'm not
afraid if my kid gets chickenpox I got
chickenpox we chickenpox parties you
can't do that in La you can't do it in
LA and if you're a doctor and you say oh
this parent didn't want their child to
get the chickenpox vaccine you get your
license taken away in a place like La I
don't think parents realize why that's
so scary not necess we can argue all day
you can call me antix I can call you
provax but as parents we should be able
to make decisions for our children I
don't fear the chicken po that's all I
was I mean yes I would I would
really not go over well in today's world
if I was a parent I I would just be in
fights and it would just be ugly and
then my kids I my hat is off to anyone
who is a parent today because I honestly
feel it has never been harder to be a
parent because you're not allowed to
boss them around what's the [__]
point of having kids if you can't boss
them around and although also how could
you possibly control a feral little
monster like that if you couldn't boss
them around it's insane that they treat
them like they're just short people like
yeah adults and that's weird too I was I
was actually talking with somebody that
was here before you came in here about
sort of the LA spell because it is
there's something weird about parents in
this particular bubble this particular
part of La where they think that the
children are adults I don't understand
you know we don't want to tell our child
no I met a parent that said that we
don't believe in telling our child no
and I just said okay well he rapes
someone 1 and he says my mom never
taught me the word no there were no
boundaries I mean whose fault is that
going to be I mean it's this country
reminds me of like a medieval European
country where a five-year-old ascends to
the throne and inherits it and so all
the cers have to pretend that whatever
brain fart whatever brain fart comes out
of the mouth of this 5-year-old toddler
yes is something that we have to take
seriously and treat as valid and and
debatable that's what this country is
that is very accurate that was a very
incredible analogy pockets of the
country though I would say Pockets
particularly here right you don't see
that stuff in Tennessee like
it yes ma'am no sir you know what I mean
and they don't play around with that
stuff and that's what I love about and
that's that's why I completely
understand I don't know Candace I I
don't I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry guys
I've been to Tennessee there is just as
much ratchet [__] there as I have seen
in other parts of the country it's maybe
a little
better um maybe there's a couple Pockets
but social media is here it is affecting
the women even the homeschooled women
you you cannot protect women from the
culture sorry I just I don't really
I I I'm not
blind um some of the most liberal chicks
from my college moved to
Tennessee and they're going to get
married and have kids so you know stand
white people move to places like Austin
and Nashville yeah and this this is what
they attacked me for so vigorously when
I did my editorial about trans which you
know I feel like again a great
demarcation between what liberal is old
school liberal and woke liberal believes
trans is of course a real thing and and
they should be protected and respected
woke is like um well before they can
like tie their shoe we tell them they
very likely might be in the wrong body I
ran your segment on my podcast actually
because it was brilliant yeah on real
time you did the segment talking about
okay if this is a real
thingal geography why is it Regional
brilliant Point that's what I was saying
why is it so Regional you what is it the
water here in California
I've been to dinner parties more than
one no but it's because women are Behind
These movements women women women it
might be a couple liberal men but they
know they can manipulate women and women
go with the culture women go with what
the culture says what is cool what is
trendy at the time where there's 12
people and they're all talking about
their trans kid they're all scary it's
almost like that's the norm yeah and
that can't really be the norm I mean I
get I get get it that things happen in
nature you
know mix up at the factory whatever you
want to call it it nature you know I
know the religious people like to call
it you know what do they say intelligent
design it's not that intelligent in a
lot of ways I mean in a lot of ways it
is but there's a lot of stuff about the
human body and the way we're built and
the way we you know like flam I feel
like is very often unnecessary and only
makes things worse I wish I could walk
in my own body and say we don't need
this FL you know I I know you're trying
to
help but you know you're not really
helping because I don't think it's stop
I think it's giving a place for the
bacteria to Nestle in right well
actually it's funny because I'm not I
cough up a bunch of FL I was I was
reading this I don't know what causes it
I can't figure out what makes must be
there must be something objectively good
about flum and now I'm interested and
this is the kind of random things that
I'll research on the internet like what
actually is purp of FL but there was a
real housewife and I cannot I will not
name her because I got in trouble on
YouTube for talking about it even though
she talked about it first and came out
and said she's got like two she's got
four kids dad's a doctor brilliant
doctor but Beverly Hills so you know
here we go here you go so how brilliant
can you really be um and especially now
that doctors don't know the difference
between the Sexes and they've got like
two non-binary children one gay child
and one trans child say that slower two
non-binary children nonbinary meaning
they are not bound to anything sex I
think how old are they uh these all of
these children are like 12 maybe 15 and
under so non-binary would that be the
same as bisexual uh I'm not sure and I
don't want to get us into trouble
because these definitions change and
they're fluid and the second you don't
get the update to Children fluid too yes
but also a trans child and like a a gay
child and I'm like this is a statistical
impossibility um obviously and they kind
of came out and said obviously this is
is going possibility something's going
on in your house and I'm going to guess
it's a lack of parenting right because
these are just the I I I didn't graduate
high school with a single effing
non-binary child so this is this is this
is made up right and you're telling me
all of your children have this thing
that didn't exist when I was in high
school in 2007 but now all of your
children are suffering from this thing
you know and that's kind of I think the
litmus test for me is like okay if this
is a real thing why did this just not
exist at all when I was in school and
it's not like they're playing catchup
it's not like now suddenly kids are
going back from my high school class and
saying I'm trans they're not we had gay
kids
a couple lesbian kids uh you know and
everyone else was you know that was it
you know like now they've got so many
options to choose from from the infinite
alphabet Community with the busy fall
America on eggs
o
what social media when
you we both say than you know you know
what we have in
common like we both say things that make
people on both sides mad we say some
things they like and some things they
don't yeah there a lot of people but
when we're in agreement about something
I think people feel the same about me in
this way like when they do agree it's
like that person really I mean rubs my
[__] on that the way they do that they
really I just love you so much when you
go off on something that deserves to be
gone off on yeah and I feel like people
feel that like when I go off on
something and it deserves that ass
kicking and you do it I mean you're
funny you have a I saw you make
doing the Eminem thing where you like
you were making fun of all his moves I
just don't know what Happ I know but it
was really funny I mean the way you just
like and I like Eminem but you made him
look ridick he rck he's now just rid I
mean you met B ramaswami it's like
you're picking on like re ramaswami he
is that's that's what I was mimicking
him because he was talking about he was
talking about Trump nuking the world
yeah that was yeah I was going back and
just showing how you know the fall wom
down but the segment that I was doing
was just about like he keeps doing this
we get it you don't like Republicans you
don't like conservatives but what did
was so harmless I mean he was in front
of like six kids rapping some Eminem
lyrics and Eminem lawyered up against
him but I did advise the when he was
here to stop rapping
yes you know I do rap a little bit I do
I do it's that is not real no really do
you guys like
Vic I'm a I'm a trump gal I think Kanye
yay I know everybody just thought thinks
he's insane and crazy I kind of like him
I kind of do Vic
Vic he's all right um I think he's a
little young for me I like the older
people I think they they bring
wisdom right right it's just not a good
look it's you know V he reminds me so
much of that character from Mean Girls
he's like a true academic High achieving
nice which girl have you ever seen Mean
Girls of course
mathletes mathet okay right and then
there's the Indian guy who raps on stage
and he's like sucker sucker sucker MC's
ain't got nothing on me but he's cooler
than he's cool no the guy is cool but
he's like he's a high achieving mathet
who also likes hip-hop he's in different
things and I loved having V on my show I
thought he was super inspirational I
like that he kind of has been staying
above The Fray because I'm super
fatigued with politics right now well
he's a lot more on your page uh with
some of these issues like global warming
than I am so you know I oh you guys want
to see them on the same
thing oh you think he's controlled
opposition huh I find him brilant as I
said to him I I find you very disarming
and also alarming
yeah yeah but that's me and I think some
of it is performative I you know he will
not admit that he wants to be the vice
president but of course Trump is going
to be the nominee so there's they're
only running for vice president at this
point would you not agree I like Larry
Elder as a VP I love Larry Elder no no
no no no obviously Ronda s is not
running to be Trump's vice president
right absolutely not you guys think
oh4 why wouldn't he take that of course
no he won't no he won't they hate each
other they hate each other Haley is not
running to be vice president do you do
you think that Lyon and John F Ken who
who would you guys want to see as VP
they didn't hate each other you think
hating someone is is disqualifies you to
serving with them as vice president it's
practically a qualification I could see
Tim Scott doing the VP thing but I think
they're all after something else because
you can also run to get your name out
because you have you want to run again
in four years you're just kind of you
know testing the water but V's young
enough that the VP office doesn't seem
for me to be his goal I could be wrong
but if I could go back just to the VP
thing only because like I've watched a
little more history because you're so
young so young wasn't even alive for the
moon landing
so the
what what happened I doubt it child um
but like usually I'm telling you the
vice president and the president hate
each other because they just ran against
each other yeah and the guy picks as the
vice president very often the person
who uh is kind of the runner up who
wants to bring in that Coalition and
also the guy who like sort of Alex Jones
for
VPO oh my God I
wish oh that would be
amazing I wish fits the thing that he
you you guys don't like Nikki Haley fun
fact I met her like years ago I mean
barely I got a picture my dad used to
really like
her I wonder if Pearl understood my
message did do I I don't know doesn't do
Pearl is vp2 I know I would I would
become president and then I would take
away women's right to vote I'd be like
guys this has got not a control Bush
picked Dan Quail because like I'm old
and experienced and and this little boy
you know yeah they used to have a much
that life as like a child yeah it was
funny I I get what you're saying you
know so I don't think I think they all
you don't think Nikki Haley no I think I
think she's going for like is she's
she's running to secure wealth cuz she
started her career
to to to do what well she was like
millions of dollars into debt right and
now she's got money pouring into her
coffers I think they have they all have
incentives and I'm not saying any of
them are pure but I think they're
different incentives I think Nikki is
motivated by money and I think that she
like the said on stage is actually
looking for a deal with like ran or
something this is how much they all
wanted though I noticed
they many of them purposely I'm sure
they know better mispronounced viv's
name they did just to get the idea uh
this person Foreigner
funny name uh veic is
ITA what is your but when Nikki Haley
did it fellow indianamerican I was like
oh Nikki not you to you don't know how
to say his name I know I don't think so
yeah I don't know how did you think she
did um as good as she could as good as
you could do in that format
um I thought she it's going to be Trump
and whoever he
wants um like Pence obviously isn't wan
to be vice president right right see
they all have different reason they're
running no he might be deluded enough to
think that Jesus Will um decide it
should be him and that's really what he
thinks makes the difference in the world
is what Jesus decides I mean I remember
having a discussion with the the old
dorm room [__] session with my
sophomore roommate and we talked about I
forget what the issue was for like 2
hours and finally he just said well
because I Think Jesus Christ will come
down and blah blah blah and I was like
why did I waste two hours if that's what
you really think about how this issue is
going to get resolved Jesus Christ is
going to come down and do this in ABC
and I think that's Mike Pence you think
Mike Mike's Pence is running because he
think Christ ordained him I think he's
running because he thinks it's in God's
hands and he's a very good friend of God
and like it doesn't look good right now
but Jesus can perform Miracles because
we know that because
of bread and Loaves and um you know
stuff walking on take I take it you're a
devout atheist devout okay gotcha I
think probably Pence is running because
he doesn't know what to do next you know
he like ran a state became the vice
president what what's the next natural
progression to think that you can be
president and also because he kind of
tried he wants to separate his brand
from Trump which I think he feels like
got murking and there's some genuine Bad
Blood there so I don't I actually
there's def oh I wonder why Trump and
Pence they don't like each
other can the chat update
me chat
chat bad yeah I don't think any of them
are running to be Trump's uh VP because
they all trashed him on the stage but
they is the only one that Trump would
consider trashed him Trump they kissed
his ass Trump yeah the only one to
trashed was Chris Christie Chris
Christie trashed him Des sandis said
nothing to be fair D sandis like didn't
say anything the whole night they they
all raised their hand when they said if
sis did the well okay but they raised
their hand except for Christie when they
said would you support him as the
nominee I mean that's pretty amazing for
a guy who's you know probably going to
be convicted for what he should be
convicted for and I'm sure we agree on
this candidate definitely should we us
about you know trying to overthrow the
government of the United States um
you're just not like you're not a weak
enough person to really like I don't buy
this this I think you I think you dance
this way because you think you have to
play Kate okay first of all
chance we almost lost America on January
6 I just don't buy that you that you're
that soft yeah I do um and just to
educate you a little on this I was
saying I don't know when I saw the video
that came out because okay back when
this happened I wasn't the
most how would I describe my political
leanings how would I describe them a lot
of people have asked
me I don't really follow the stuff in
the Middle
East I'm open to learning about it right
but I wouldn't say that I really follow
the Middle Eastern conflict all that
that
closely I more follow what's going on
with family court and laws surrounding
the
family okay all right that's that's more
what I talk about
however um really what confused me was
when the January 6th thing happened I
heard about it I heard it was bad
whatever and then I saw the video like
later that came
out and it was just them like walking
through the capital I'm like what I
thought like the country was
something this for five years when
everyone was laughing at me for saying
this that Trump would never concede the
election and he would never go away I
was all alone on a raft but I mean you
saw BLM riots right yes the summer
leading up to this right where like you
I lived in DC at this time where you
couldn't go outside cars were flipped
things were burned people were boarding
up their windows but you thought the end
of democracy you can say this meaningful
face happened when people above the age
of like 65 stormed the cap like you
thought that was the worst thing you've
ever seen in in American politics well I
mean what was the worst scene that was a
small part of a bigger picture the worst
the worst thing
was that finally we had a president
after all this history that we've had
nobody ever did this not Al Gore and not
Nixon who probably didn't actually lose
their elections they allowed this
peaceful transfer of power to happen we
finally had a guy who decided of course
because he's insane decided that no
matter what happens I won this election
there's only two things that could
possibly happen I win the election or if
I don't win the election there must have
been some cheating it was looked at by
his own people around him including the
Homeland Security Department including
the Director of National Intelligence
including every Court federal and state
including the his own lawyers his
daughter Bill bar everybody told him you
lost this election they looked at this
over and over again even the Republican
vote counters like the one he called who
said find me 11,000 more votes even
those people told him so plainly he he
did not accept losing the election and
then he tried to put in aund this is why
he's on trial it's not you believe that
that that day as the media we're talking
about media hoaxes I just I gave you my
answer it's not just that day although
that was part of the scheme I mean it's
not like coincidence that they showed up
on the very day that they were
certifying the vote at the very place
they were doing it to stop that from
happening that's not a CO have any
questions about why the FBI hasn't been
able to find since we're we started with
media hoaxes you think it's strange that
they haven't been able to find who
dropped off the pipe bombs the night
before cuz I think that's the strangest
piece what pipe bombs oh this is some
red herring [__] no no not Redang
this is in the moves you can watch the
CNN MSNBC you know remember the night
before on January 5th there were pipe
bombs that were uh uh set outside of the
RNC and the DNC headquarters right and
this was a part of the whole
what thing that bombs were about to go
off but they were they were able to you
know get the bomb out this is why you
know AOC said she have f for all this
stuff so I'm asking you do you have more
pressing questions about why they have
not been able to find the person that
dropped off those I will have to look
into that the way you'll have to look
into the moon thing okay because I think
that's a very big piece for a lot of
people of just understanding like what
actually happened on that day as I said
before I don't trust the media on
anything because they never give you the
full story so I will allow that there
could be this element to the story that
is part of the story I don't think it
will probably change my mind that Donald
Trump would not concede an election kept
saying it was a sorry I think it's fake
too that's my
feelings that's my
feelings I I just look it guys I've been
alive for 26 years almost 27
now and in my lifetime um I've never
gone to bed and had the election switch
I've never had it s
like and and and and on my birthday
Democrats always win my birthday is the
4th of November and
um and what happened was election day
was on can't even remember but I just
remember it I thought we were going to
win because election day was the day
before my birthday and Republicans
always win when it doesn't fall on my
birthday I think I was born to be
political because I was literally born
on the 4th fake and and that he had all
these uh reasons to to believe that the
that people had voted like 10, all right
I'm kind of done with thousand he said
to the renberger on the call I Ren
actually corrected him and said you know
you you claimed that there was 10,000
dead people who voted in Georgia we
looked and we looked and we looked it
was two that sums it all up there was
actually two now he's not on trial for
lying you're apparently about to allowed
to lie to the American people about
elections even though nobody ever really
did that before but okay he's on trial
for breaking specific laws forgery I
meany Stacy Abrams it so as a Layman as
just a person that tunes into
politics I've been hearing for years
that they're going to get Trump on
something and you could only say this to
me for so many years until I just start
to not believe it maybe it's possible I
don't know I don't know
but I don't know anyways guys um like
the video on your way out I might finish
this next week let me know if you guys
want me to do more political stuff if
you like this if you didn't like it you
know F off I don't care like the video
on your way out guys um subscribe to the
channel and